the season finale of Rapunzel's tangled
adventure left us totally flabbergasted
let's take a look at why cassandra
portrayed Rapunzel and why she wasn't at
Rapunzel and Eugene's wedding I now
pronounce you husband and wife you may
kiss when Disney released tangled in
2010 everyone fell in love with the
spunky new Princess Rapunzel made the
best out of being trapped in a tower for
her entire life she escapes with Flynn
Rider to see the floating lanterns she
befriends bad guys and falls in love and
she discovers the truth she is the lost
princess with Flynn's help rapunzel
defeats Mother Gothel and reunites with
her real parents
the movie had an amazing soundtrack and
was super hilarious all the characters
were so great
Flynn whose real name is Eugene stole
our hearts and Pascal the chameleon is
one of the best animal companions a
princess could ever ask for
we loved everything about this movie and
Disney gave us the happily ever after
that we wanted a couple of years later
they released tangle ever after
this short film is only six minutes long
and it's so cute
Pascal and Max have to find the wedding
rings for Eugene and Rapunzel they do
and the wedding is epic these two are so
in love the castle is packed and
everyone who is anyone is there or are
they there is one person who is totally
missing from the wedding and this isn't
just some minor character Rapunzel's BFF
Cassandra is nowhere in sight Cassandra
is the captain of the guards daughter
she's also Rapunzel's lady-in-waiting
while they are on their adventure they
encounter some magical rocks these cause
Rapunzel's magical blond hair to grow
back Disney launched a whole series
about Rapunzel's life after marriage it
takes place between the original movie
and tangled ever after one of the best
parts of the show is Cassandra Rapunzel
grew up totally isolated when she was
locked away by Mother Gothel she never
had any friends besides Pascale and a
girl needs a bestie
we loved the friendship between these
two Cassandra is such a cool character
her dream is to become captain of the
guard she doesn't really want to be a
lady-in-waiting because well the girl's
a fighter her father taught her how to
fight when she was very young she knows
all about being a guard but because she
is his daughter and a girl she doesn't
get to be one of the guards still she
does get to fight alongside them a few
times she even leads a siege once or
twice but even though it's not her dream
she takes her job as Rapunzel's
lady-in-waiting
seriously she seems to really love and
care for Rapunzel and because she's such
a great fighter she acts as Rapunzel's
bodyguard a lot Rapunzel and Cassandra
are really close friends they share a
lot in common
despite their very different upbringing
Cassandra is definitely more than an
employee these two spends most of the
series side by side that's why we were
so shocked when Cassandra portrayed
Rapunzel and because the moonstone
turned her totally evil she must have a
corrupted heart if you really look back
at season 2 you'll see that kiss and
just starts changing thank you with the
scratching what could you possibly be
drawing in that journal now she becomes
more and more distant from Rapunzel and
Eugene poor Rapunzel Cassandra looks
super powerful we just know that season
3 is going to be crazy
who is Cassandra we thought we knew who
Cassandra was but apparently we're all
wrong
Cassandra was adopted by the captain of
the guard so we don't actually know who
her real parents are she could be anyone
she has dark hair and green eyes which
reminds us of a certain villain in fact
the resemblance between mother Gothel
and Cassandra is pretty obvious we don't
know when season 3 will be back but we
do know what the season premiere is
called it's called Cassandra's revenge
Cassandra is about the same age as
Rapunzel and she had a pretty good life
what does she need revenge for in the
end being excluded from the guard isn't
a good reason to turn evil she obviously
needs revenge for something major one of
the leading fan theories is that
Cassandra is the child of Mother Gothel
whoa let that sink in for a minute
but how did it get and you find out the
best explanation is that it was revealed
to her in Rapunzel topia the gang ends
up in that creepy house cassandra gets
sucked into a strange room she comes out
at the end of the episode she could have
learned the truth about her parentis and
there but she knows how awful mother
Gothel was which she really decide to
side with her deceased mom that just
doesn't seem like something Cassandra
would do but if something or someone
manipulated her she might truly believe
that her mom was a victim that is
definitely an explanation for why
Cassandra would turn evil and want the
moonstone but we aren't so sure that she
is just mother Goethals daughter it just
seems like such a sudden change and we
know that it was someone with a
corrupted heart takes the
stone it will be Bad News Bears we think
Cassandra might have a corrupted heart
from earlier on maybe she has known all
along that she is Goethals daughter or
maybe just maybe she is someone else
entirely she might actually be Mother
Gothel reincarnated we know this sounds
absurd but hear us out
mother Gothel was extremely powerful of
course a lot of her power emanated from
Rapunzel's hair but not all of it and
when she dies entangled she literally
turns into dust
her body is nowhere to be found what if
this is just magic what if she survived
could she be cassandra in disguise or
cassandra could be Mother Gothel
reincarnated through magic Mother Gothel
definitely has a lot of reasons to get
revenge and we know that she is super
evil has she been tricking Rapunzel all
along it wouldn't be the first time that
Rapunzel think someone is kind-hearted
only to realize that they're actually
evil it's kind of Goethals MO and she
had years to learn exactly how to
manipulate Rapunzel she would know how
to become her bestie from the very
beginning there is another option for
Cassandra's true identity and this all
goes back to the Mirror Mirror episode
Cassandra gets stuck in that strange
room but remember what else was
happening in that creepy in everyone was
being replaced by evil doppelgangers
this place and its owner Matthews had
the ability to make body doubles of
everyone all of which were evil beyond
belief
Rapunzel saves the day and all her
friends but what if she didn't save
everyone Cassandra could be a
doppelganger now it's after this that
Cassandra starts acting weird and she
manipulates Rapunzel into letting her go
with her to get the moonstone Rapunzel
wasn't sure she trusted Cassandra
anymore but she went ahead and let her
tag along it's totally possible that she
was replaced by a body double a few
episodes earlier it could be any minion
of Matthews it could also be Mother
Gothel if she didn't really pass away
maybe she's stuck in the house but that
wouldn't explain why she isn't at
Rapunzel's wedding we're pretty sure
that Rapunzel will defeat moonstone in
season 3 if it's not really Cassandra
Rapunzel would totally forgive her as
much as we don't want to believe
Cassandra is evil we aren't sure this is
a viable theory Zahn theory many fans
believe that Cassandra strange behavior
has everything to do with the Zahn
theory here's a quick refresher on who
this evil dude is Zahn theory is an
ancient demon
he unleashed a massive Blizzard on
Corona we also know that Mother Gothel
was a follower of zonte Ruiz they have
some powers that make them vicious
enemies basically zante ruiz followers
are zealots they have created an evil
cult based on the demon it's actually
pretty scary zante Ruiz followers don't
want the Sun drop to succeed they would
definitely be after the moonstone that's
why it has been so hidden for so long
what does this have to do with Cassandra
well we think she is a follower of Zhaan
Kyrie's as well this would definitely
corrupt her heart we don't know whether
she was converted during season 2 or
earlier it could have happened in Mira
Mira
Rapunzel topia or a couple of other
times or maybe she has been a follower
of Zhaan theories all along she would
know all about Rapunzel as the Sun drop
it's possible that she's been a follower
in disguise all along of course she is
suspicious of a duda in season 2 you
might think it's because she thinks
Adira is evil but maybe she is worried
that a dealer will blow her cover and
mess up her plans what will happen in
season 3 season 3 will be the final
season of Rapunzel's tangled adventure
and the show's creators have some
serious explaining to do we have some
theories about what will happen in
season 3 the first has to do with
defeating Cassandra the Ancients girls
prophecy said that someone must wield
both the Sun Drop and the moon stone to
bring balance this was Rapunzel's
destiny she is the Sun Drop but she
needs the moon stone currently Cassandra
is the moon stone because she is wearing
it but if she is wearing it like jewelry
it can come off there will be an epic
showdown between cassandra and rapunzel
Rapunzel will get the moonstone and be
able to wield both of them but what will
happen to Cassandra will she come to her
senses and turn good again we don't
think this is likely there's a reason
that Cassandra is not at Rapunzel's
wedding if they made up and Cassandra
proved herself to be good
Rapunzel would definitely want her best
friend by her side Cassandra is going to
end up meeting in early fate or entity
arrested and in prison but since it's a
kids show we're hoping she just goes to
jail we also think that Zahn tiri is
going to come back we know he needs
three main followers he used to have
Matthews and Mother Gothel but what if
his new followers include var Ian and
Cassandra remember var Ian he was the
young Alchemist
wanted the Sun drop he portrayed
Rapunzel in season 1 and were not so
sure that we've seen the last of him he
seems to be the perfect follower for
zhan teary he uses magic to get what he
wants and he's hell-bent on getting his
revenge the power that Zahn teary could
offer would definitely appeal to VAR iam
Cassandra is also a good candidate from
one of Santi Rees main followers this is
especially true since she currently
wills the powers of the moonstone for
some reason she is also seeking revenge
this is a powerful motivator to do evil
things
the third follower might be Hector ever
since he came into contact with the
spirit of zon teary he has not been the
same
together these three could be strong
enough to bring Zahn to be back from his
home realm that would make an evil
ancient demon the main villain of season
3 things are definitely going to get
complicated happily ever after we know
that Rapunzel and Eugene will live
happily ever after we've seen their
wedding but we think it's going to take
a lot to get there season 3 is going to
be action-packed and wild at the very
least they have to defeat Cassandra with
her new moonstone powers they might be
facing downs on tier II and his other
followers too we are pretty sure that
Cassandra's true identity is really
important to the plot and it's also why
she doesn't come to Rapunzel's wedding
it's hard to come back from betraying
your BFF we feel really bad for Rapunzel
her first ever friend has turned out to
be evil who do you think Cassandra
really is what do you think will happen
in season 3 don't be shy tell us your
theories in the comments section give
this video a big thumbs up if you think
Rapunzel and Eugene are
relationshipgoals
and be sure to subscribe to the things
for the latest Disney news thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]